Oz has a question about red flags I like
red flags let's do that question Oz how
you doing buddy you're muted by the way
all right can you hear me
yeah what's your question you got for me
yeah so
now in your book you say it's 20 red
flags and uh I haven't read the whole
book yet but um but I'm curious to know
if because most of the women in Western
countries they they're gonna have bad
Flags right so are there any red flags
that the woman can have that she can
work on or or the man can accept it for
example I'll give an example a
promiscuous thing cannot be fixed like
once it's done the damage is done hissy
fix maybe you know someone can work on
their attitude and they can fix it so
are they list of any red flags that that
can be fixed
yeah so that's a good question
um so if you guys haven't got the red
flag chapter here let me put the banner
down at the bottom uh so change the
ticker you can opt into my email list go
into entrepreneurs and cars.com forward
slash red Dash Flags you can get the red
flag chapter for free there's 20 red
flags
so let me just look at my list over here
because I've got in front of me so there
are certain things that can be fixed and
fixing these things by the way has to be
their choice you can't say fix this red
flag or else it has to be like the way
that I would generally handle it so
let's say that um
I don't know uh she's the kind of gal
that competes with you okay uh my car's
faster than you my house is nicer than
yours blah blah blah you know like that
kind of chick
then all you have to say is look Becky I
really like you and everything but I
don't date girls that try to compete
with me
that's all you have to say now
you leave that ball in in her court and
you plant the seed and let her see if
she's going to do something about that
if she's going to protest if she's going
to boss [__] you out and just you know
lecture you then it's a lost cause just
let it go and you should have other
options that's like the whole point of
spinning plates so if you want to be a
little more pointed about it then you
can say look you know you've got extreme
jealousy issues I really think that you
should see a therapist about that and
see if you can fix it because you're
making mountains out of mole Hills out
of things that don't exist and I don't
date women that are gonna you know
behave like that you know sort of thing
or I'm not going to invite a woman like
that into my life on a long-term basis
is another way to put it so again uh Oz
it's got to be a choice that they make
it's not something that you can cram
down their throat and there's certain
things that they can't change you know
like you said like if she's a single mom
she's not going to change that if she's
got a huge Notch count she can't change
that but if she's the kind of girl
that's using Instagram to seek
validation and attention online from
other people specifically men you could
tell her look I don't date girls that
use Instagram to seek attention and
validation from other men you can use
how much energy sorry how much energy or
how how much uh because you gotta you
got to be able to communicate that
message across right and some girls will
will uh respond in a different way so
how how much how many times do you have
to reiterate that to a girl that hey
mate or I I don't like this thing or I
don't like the girl who's seeking
attention because I know in long term
it's going to be detrimental uh have a
detrimental effect on a relationship
um
I don't think that it should be an
ongoing conversation it should be stated
it should be stated firmly and it
shouldn't have to be restated on a
continuous basis I mean for example so
let's use the seeking attention online
like the Instagram girl yeah Becky I
really dig your Vibe and everything I
have a lot of fun with you you know
because she's having the conversations
now like where do we stand or really
yeah exactly you know you've seen
anybody else okay hey Becky and I really
dig your Vibe too I think you're a lot
of fun but I don't invite women into my
life that use social media to seek
attention validation from other guys
online so if you want to be with me you
can either make your Instagram private
and just use it to post you know
photographs of family events and stuff
like that like most people do or you can
delete it
right that's it and then see what she
does with that yep
you're too controlling you've got a
small PP you know she freaks out [__]
off we'll see you later go away I'm done
with you yeah because you have other
options just but a good woman will say
just one more you're absolutely right
yeah look I think that's right but they
decide for the time being and they come
back with the same they go back to
square one and they go okay maybe the
whole thing that I just explained last
week didn't uh resonated with them for
too long so that's the
that's where it is um you had a good
question today life you know the the
promiscuous woman or the single mom I've
dated both the I wanted to know was
there age age bracket for these girls
like were they like a 20 year old single
mom or 20 year old promiscuous girl or
whatever was the question so I don't
know 30 year old twins yeah 30 year old
yeah definitely the the promiscuous girl
in that case not that they're they're
choose a she's any good but if I've only
got two options then that'll be the the
choice
for the 10 group uh you said you started
10 group where people can uh join in
what's the um what what do we get for
the 10 uh for people who wants
interested in joining in that 10 group
good question
um you can go to the website
entrepreneurs and cars.com forward slash
community and it's all explained on that
page uh you're in Australia by the way
um there was a bunch of Aussies that
just had to meet up on the Gold Coast
um so we do have members there we don't
have a ton but we do have members here
if you're making over a hundred thousand
dollars a year then the one percent is a
better group for you if you're if you're
a little bit of a younger guy you're you
know trying to hash out you know life in
some basic details and the ten percent's
a good starting place
okay and do we get to ask questions in
those calls with you or
not with me there's monthly Zoom calls
with the admin uh guys there's four
admin guys right now uh two of them are
in the live chat uh Jaren and uh moff
um and there's a couple others as well
so they run the zoom calls I'm not in
the zoom calls the 10 is not a group
that I run to be clear it's run by the
Admin guys uh-huh it's basically a
staging area for you guys to graduate up
to the next uh which is the one that I
run cool all right thanks very much
cheers all right thanks man I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out